Pat Garrett once admitted that the thing he
feared most was having his life defined by
just one moment - the killing of William H.
Bonney, better known as Billy the Kid. He
said he dreaded meeting new people because
they always said something along the lines
of “Hey! You’re Pat Garrett, the guy who
shot Billy the Kid!”
Unfortunately for the lawman, his worst fear
came to pass. Not only in his lifetime, but
also in modern times, his legacy is inexorably
tied to the killing of Bonney, which I guess
is just what happens when you gun down one
of the biggest icons of the Wild West.
There was another problem. As the outlaw’s
reputation grew and he was turned into a legend
of the Old West, sympathy for him increased
and Garrett, slowly but surely, was becoming
the villain of this tale. Sure, Billy the
Kid was a ruthless murderer who killed many
men in cold blood, but people could not help
but feel like Garrett acted somewhat cowardly
by gunning him down in the dark. That was
not how the heroes of the Wild West acted
in their imaginations. If the two had met
in a duel, then the story would probably have
been remembered vastly different. Bonus “cool
points” for Garrett if he would have said
a snappy one-liner before shooting and lit
a cigar afterwards.
As it stands, though, Pat Garrett sits in
a grey area of western lore where some people
admire him as a tough lawman in a lawless
land and others brand him a coward. But, as
we are about to see, his life continued with
other thrills and adventures after the death
of Bonney, culminating with Garrett’s own
mysterious murder that still puzzles people
to this day.
Early Years
He was born Patrick Floyd Jarvis Garrett on
June 5, 1850, in Chambers County, Alabama,
to John Lumpkin Garrett and Elizabeth Jarvis.
At a young age, he relocated with his family
to Louisiana after his father bought a cotton
plantation in Claiborne Parish.
At first, things went pretty well for the
Garrett family as the plantation flourished,
but things took a drastic turn for the worse
when the Civil War broke out. It completely
ruined the family’s finances and then both
parents died less than a year apart in 1867
and 1868, respectively, leaving behind a plantation
full of debt. Pat’s younger siblings were
taken in by various relatives. However, as
Garrett turned 18 years old, he saw no reason
to stick around anymore and, in 1869, rode
alone into the sunset.
Image: Bison skull pyramid
https://commons.wikimedia.org/wiki/File:Bison_skull_pile_edit.jpg
Very few details are known about the next
years of Garrett’s life. He settled in Texas
for a while, near the Dallas area, where he
worked as a farmhand. A few years later, he
became a buffalo hunter on the Staked Plains
and started a business selling their hides.
However, this was not a sustainable career.
People like Garrett almost hunted the American
buffalo (which is actually a bison if we are
being technical) into extinction. Tens of
millions of specimens were killed during the
19th century, at one point reducing their
numbers to only a few hundred in the entire
country. Once the supply started running out,
Garrett left Texas and drifted towards Fort
Sumner in New Mexico.
Before we get there, however, there is still
another important event from Pat Garrett’s
life to discuss - the first time he killed
a man. It happened around 1876 and the victim
was a friend of Garrett’s and fellow buffalo
hunter named Joe Briscoe. The two of them
got into an argument, who knows over what,
and it escalated to the point of violence.
An enraged Briscoe charged at Garrett with
an axe, prompting the latter to grab a pistol
and shoot his attacker at point-blank range.
Allegedly, as he lay there dying, Briscoe
was the one who asked forgiveness of his shooter,
reducing Garrett to tears. Racked with guilt,
the killer tried to turn himself in at Fort
Griffin, but the authorities there had no
interest in prosecuting him so Garrett just
went on with his life.
Image: Peter Maxwell ranch
https://www.legendsofamerica.com/wp-content/uploads/2017/06/Pete-Maxwells-house-1882.jpg
When he arrived in New Mexico, Garrett found
work as a cowboy again at Pedro “Pete”
Maxwell’s ranch. This is the same house
where he would kill Billy the Kid a few years
later. During this time, he also married a
woman named Juanita Gutierrez who would die
less than a year into their marriage during
childbirth. Garrett would not stay single
for long, though, as in 1880 he remarried
to Apolinaria Gutierrez, the 17-year-old younger
sister of his first wife. They would go on
to have eight children together.
The Lincoln County War
That same year, Garrett was elected sheriff
of Lincoln County, New Mexico Territory, and
immediately set his sights on Billy the Kid
and the other gunslingers he rode with.
By this point, Billy the Kid had already earned
his fame thanks to his involvement in the
Lincoln County War which you can learn about
in-depth in our Biographics video on “Billy
the Kid”.
Link suggestion: Billy the Kid
https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=Gt303JRUCsE
Basically, the Lincoln County War was a violent
feud that started in 1878 between two factions
that both wanted a monopoly over the dry goods
business. On one side there was the older,
established group led by James Dolan and Lawrence
Murphy who already operated the largest general
goods store in Lincoln County known simply
as “The House”. On the other was the new
partnership between businessmen John Tunstall
and Alexander McSween who opened a rival store.
To add fuel to the fire, both groups also
had some serious backup in the form of gangs
willing to protect their side’s interests
with violent diligence. Dolan’s faction
had the Jesse Evans Gang, better known as
the Boys, and also had the county sheriff
William J. Brady in his pocket. The newcomers
had the Regulators, a group of loosely-affiliated
cowboys and ranch hands who had a history
with one another. They included Billy the
Kid and other desperados such as Dick Brewer,
Doc Scurlock, the Coe cousins, Tom O’Folliard,
and Charlie Bowdre.
The Lincoln County War kicked off properly
on February 18, 1878, when the Boys killed
John Tunstall. That’s when the Regulators
formed into a more cohesive gang and, at the
start at least, even had the law on their
side as they received warrants from Justice
of the Peace John Wilson to bring Tunstall’s
killers to justice.
This feud was marked by multiple shootouts
and revenge killings. Billy the Kid and a
few other Regulators killed Sheriff Brady.
Although dozens of other people died, this
was the murder that would send Bonney on the
run with Pat Garrett on his trail. The war
culminated with a five-day shootout known
as the Battle of Lincoln where Alexander McSween
was also killed. With both businessmen dead,
the Regulators had nobody to work for anymore
so they scattered.
The First Pursuit
By the time Garrett started chasing Billy
the Kid, the latter was already a notorious
gunman known throughout the country. He and
a few other Regulators like Bowdre and O’Folliard
decided to stick together after the Lincoln
County War and engage in additional acts of
mayhem, violence, and murder. They also joined
up with “Dirty” Dave Rudabaugh, another
infamous outlaw of the Old West.
Image: Dave Rudabaugh
Billy the Kid’s gang first crossed guns
with Garrett in late 1880. On December 19,
the gang rode into Fort Sumner, New Mexico,
where Garrett was already waiting for them,
assisted by another lawman named Lon Chambers.
He confronted Tom O’Folliard and another
former Regulator named Tom Pickett. When O’Folliard
went for his gun, Garrett shot him in the
chest. He died less than an hour later, aged
22, but the other outlaws managed to make
a run for it.
Image: Tom O’Folliard
The lawman stayed in hot pursuit. Just a few
days later, on December 23, he tracked the
whole gang to an abandoned farmhouse near
Stinking Springs, New Mexico, and, this time,
he had a large posse with him. It seemed like
Garrett had the situation completely in control,
but the gang still preferred a shootout over
surrender. Former Regulator Charlie Bowdre
was killed during this encounter. The rest
eventually came to their senses and gave up
after a two-day siege.
Image: Charlie Bowdre
The Kid Escapes and Second Pursuit
If this would have been the end of the road
for Billy the Kid, Garrett might have been
unanimously remembered as a hero. He was brave
and diligent in his pursuit of the outlaws,
only killed when absolutely necessary and
managed to bring all the other criminals to
justice. Unsurprisingly, Bonney was convicted
for the murder of Sheriff Brady and sentenced
to hang until he was “dead, dead, dead”,
which is what the judge told him, according
to legend.
However, on April 28, while awaiting execution,
Bonney managed to outmaneuver his guards.
When only one deputy named James Bell was
watching him, he asked to be taken to the
outhouse where he attacked his sentry. The
Kid shot and killed Bell with his own gun.
Afterwards, he armed himself with a shotgun,
waited for Bob Ollinger, the other guard,
to return and killed him, too. Bonney then
jumped on a horse and rode out of town.
Image suggestion: Ollinger plaque
https://en.wikipedia.org/wiki/File:Bob_Ollinger_death_marker.JPG
Garrett wasn’t in town when Billy the Kid
escaped, but he soon returned and started
chasing him again.
A few months later, the lawman heard that
his fugitive had returned to Fort Sumner.
He went to visit Pete Maxwell’s ranch because
he suspected that Bonney might be hiding there.
The exact sequence of events is up for some
debate but, according to the most common version,
on the night of July 14, Garrett was sitting
in the dark in Maxwell’s bedroom. Bonney
entered the room and asked who was there and,
upon recognizing his voice, the sheriff shot
him twice without saying anything. Billy the
Kid was dead before he hit the ground.
Aftermath
Word of the outlaw’s demise traveled fast.
As the story of Billy the Kid was plastered
on every newspaper in the country, Bonney
was slowly being turned into a folk hero rather
than a lifelong criminal who was on the run
after mercilessly killing two deputies. Moreover,
Garrett was the one that the media chose to
portray as the cold-blooded assassin.
He couldn’t stand this so, in 1882, he wrote
his own account with the help of a ghostwriter
to set the record straight. It was titled
“The Authentic Life of Billy, the Kid”
and it became, for a while, the definitive
version of the events that went down at Peter
Maxwell’s ranch. However, it was later found
to contain many inaccuracies and historians
dismissed it as an embellished narrative with
the occasional truth thrown in.
While the newspapers went way overboard with
their sympathetic portrayal of Billy the Kid
because it made a better story, Garrett’s
account veered too much in the opposite direction
as its main goal was to clear his own name
rather than give a factual description of
the events.
Most notably, Garrett’s version changes
the part where he gunned down Bonney in the
dark without giving him a chance to surrender.
In a “Han shot first”-type scenario, the
sheriff alleged that the Kid raised his cocked
pistol a foot away from Garrett, thus leaving
him with no choice but to pull the trigger.
Businessman Garrett
Garrett did not seek re-election as sheriff
and, instead, had a brief stint with the Texas
Rangers. After that was over, he left law
enforcement for about a decade, time during
which he tried to enter the irrigation industry.
Garrett lived on a large ranch near Roswell,
New Mexico. He soon realized that in many
arid, undeveloped regions of the Southwest,
irrigation was a necessity for any kind of
successful agriculture. In his area, that
irrigation would have come courtesy of the
Pecos River which Garrett thought could be
dammed and used to construct a large-scale
canal. One anecdote that definitely isn’t
true even stated that he originally got the
idea from Billy the Kid who told him that
he could grow crops and make lots of money
instead of chasing guys like him.
During the mid 1880s, Garrett met businessman
Charles Eddy who was in the process of buying
as much land as possible with his own plans
to invest into an irrigation system. Eventually,
the two decided to combine their ventures
for one large reclamation project. They were
also joined by a third entrepreneur called
Charles Greene and, in 1888, the “Pecos
Irrigation and Investment Company” was born.
As the company grew and more businessmen joined
the project, Garrett was slowly relegated
to an increasingly smaller role. Although
this could have been done because others were
simply more experienced than him, one Garrett
biographer asserts that it was a deliberate
effort to push him out of the company.
The lawman wasn’t quite ready to leave the
business completely so, instead, he purchased
one-third interest in the “Texas Irrigation
Ditch Company” and formed another business
called the “Holloman and Garrett Ditch Company”
with entrepreneur William Holloman. Both companies
failed and, eventually, Garrett abandoned
this foray completely and relocated to Uvalde,
Texas.
The Fountain Mystery
After almost a decade and a half of relative
obscurity, Pat Garrett was, once again, in
the headlines in 1896 due to his involvement
in the disappearance case of Colonel Albert
Jennings Fountain and his eight-year-old son,
Henry.
Image: Albert Fountain
Fountain was an attorney with the Texas Senate
who made a lot of dangerous enemies when he
went after powerful men involved in cattle
rustling in the New Mexico territory. In late
January, 1896, he and his son were traveling
by wagon back home to Mesilla, New Mexico.
They disappeared and were presumed murdered
on February 1 near White Sands in Doña Ana
County.
Suspicion fell on two wealthy ranchers and
rivals of Fountain - Oliver Lee and Albert
Fall. The scandal was front-page news across
the country. Governor William Thornton wanted
the matter resolved so he coaxed Pat Garrett
out of retirement by making him the Sheriff
of Doña Ana County.
Garrett located the spot where the presumed
murders took place. The ground was soaked
in blood and there was a smaller pool of blood
a few feet away. Searching the area, the sheriff
and his posse also found empty cartridge casings,
Fountain’s tie, some of his papers, and
his buckboard wagon stained with blood. It
was pretty clear that something very violent
took place there, but investigators were never
able to find the bodies. To make matters more
difficult, tracks that led away from the area
had been “accidentally” erased by a passing
herd of cattle which, by complete coincidence,
belonged to Oliver Lee.
Garrett thought Lee was the culprit, alongside
two of the rancher’s employees, Jim Gililland
and William McNew. The sheriff obtained arrest
warrants for all three. He placed McNew in
custody, but the other two men made a run
for it.
Garrett pursued the murder suspects and, on
July 12, 1898, he caught up to them at the
Wildy Well Ranch near the Jarilla Mountains.
A shootout ensued, but it did not go in Garrett’s
favor. One of his deputies, Kent Kearney,
was hit twice. As his situation was deteriorating,
the sheriff was forced to back down and call
a truce so that he could get medical attention
for his deputy. Kearney died on the way to
Las Cruces.
The Trial
Lee and Gililland stayed on the run for another
eight months before finally surrendering.
At trial, they were represented by Albert
Fall, the other landowner who hated Fountain
and, according to some, might have even orchestrated
the whole assassination plot. Now, Fall was
not just a wealthy rancher. He was also a
good lawyer and an influential politician.
In fact, he would later serve as Secretary
of the Interior under President Warren G.
Harding. Thanks to his involvement in the
Teapot Dome Scandal, Fall has the dubious
distinction of being the first U.S. cabinet
member in history to be convicted and serve
prison time for a felony.
Image: Albert B. Fall
During the trial, Garrett’s reputation worked
against him. Lee argued that the shootout
at Wildy Well was in self-defense because
Pat Garrett had no intention of taking him
and Gililland alive. If they surrendered,
the sheriff would have gunned them down in
cold blood. This story alongside Fall’s
adept defense and the lack of bodies ensured
that the suspects walked away free, not even
being charged in Deputy Kearney’s death.
Not only that, but Oliver Lee went on to have
a successful political career and today there
is a state park named after him in Otero County.
Nobody else was ever charged in connection
with the murders and the disappearance of
Albert and Henry Fountain remains one of New
Mexico’s biggest unsolved mysteries.
Presidential Appointee
The last highlight of Garrett’s law enforcement
career happened in 1899 when he was pursuing
a fugitive wanted for murder named Norman
Newman. The chase ended in a gunfight where
the sheriff shot the criminal and, thus, Norman
Newman became, to our knowledge, the last
man killed by Pat Garrett.
Garrett had a stroke of luck in 1901 when
Teddy Roosevelt became President of the United
States. Roosevelt had a deep fondness for
famed frontier lawmen who he said “correspond
to those Vikings, like Hastings and Rollo,
who finally served the cause of civilization”.
He gave jobs to several of them over the course
of his two terms as president including Seth
Bullock of Deadwood fame and Bat Masterson.
Consequently, in 1901, Pat Garrett became
collector of customs in El Paso.
Garrett’s appointment was not well-received.
Despite numerous complaints, Roosevelt seemed
determined to stick by his man. Allegedly,
the last straw came when Garrett attended
a presidential party and brought along a guest
named Tom Powers. He introduced him to the
president as a successful cattleman and the
two took several photos together, only for
Roosevelt to find out later that Powers was,
actually, the owner of a notorious saloon
in El Paso. After that, the president refused
to renew Garrett’s appointment in 1905.
The Strange Demise of Pat Garrett
Image: Jesse Wayne Brazel
Most of the popular icons of the Wild West
met violent ends and Pat Garrett was no exception.
On February 29, 1908, he was shot on the way
to Las Cruces, New Mexico, and died aged 57.
Ostensibly, his killer was a man named Jesse
Wayne Brazel who acted in self-defense. He
turned himself in and confessed. At his trial,
he was defended by none other than Albert
Fall and he was acquitted. It would appear
to be case closed, except that none of Garrett’s
relatives and, indeed, most historians believe
that Brazel was actually the one who pulled
the trigger.
There are a lot of conspiracy theories floating
around regarding Garrett’s murder. Here
are the facts, as best we know them, and you
can form your own opinion. Garrett was in
a dispute with Brazel over some land that
the former had leased to the latter for five
years. Garrett wanted to break the lease when
he discovered that Brazel was going to use
his property for goat grazing. Also involved
was a man named Print Rhode, a friend of Brazel’s
and an enemy of Garrett who had run-ins with
him while still a sheriff. We should also
mention W. W. Cox, a wealthy rancher from
the area who also hated Garrett and possibly
wanted his land.
Eventually, the two sides reached an agreement
where Brazel would terminate his lease if
he had a buyer for his goatherd. That is where
another man named Carl Adamson came in. The
exact details of the agreement are a bit murky,
but they are besides the point. What mattered
was that on the morning of February 29, Pat
Garrett, Adamson, and Brazel were traveling
together to Las Cruces. That is when Brazel
shot Garrett twice and then turned himself
in to the Doña Ana County sheriff’s office,
exclaiming “Lock me up! I’ve just killed
Pat Garrett!”
Adamson acted as witness and corroborated
Brazel’s story that an argument caused Garrett
to reach for his shotgun but Brazel drew quicker.
And, who knows, maybe this was, indeed, what
happened.
There were a few things suspicious about Garrett’s
death such as the fact that, allegedly, the
former sheriff was shot in the back of the
head and this was never brought up at trial.
And speaking of the trial, how come, of all
people, Albert Fall was the one who defended
Brazel? He had close ties to the judge and
the prosecutor in the case and also rancher
W. W. Cox who some see as the mastermind of
this whole plot.
Garrett’s son believed Adamson was the killer
and some agree. Others think it was Print
Rhode who caught up to the trio and took his
revenge. And there’s another major suspect
we haven’t even mentioned yet - an outlaw
named Jim Miller, better known as “Killin’
Jim” or “Killer Miller” who sometimes
acted as gun-for-hire and just happened to
be in the area. One popular theory says that
Miller was paid by Cox to do the deed.
We probably won’t agree on what happened
since none of us can know for certain. What
we can agree on is that getting shot in the
back of the head and being dumped on the side
of the road was a disgraceful, undeserving
end for a man once called by “Billy the
Kid” historian Walter Noble Burns as the
“last great sheriff of the old frontier”.